Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table".
Très heureuse de vous retrouver
autour d'un plat,
d'un dessert et d'un invité,
pour parler cuisine, alimentation,
écologie mais aussi
un peu politique.
Nous recevons
un invité exceptionnel :
Philippe Geluck.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour, Brigitte.
-Merci d'être avec nous.
Avec moi pour la présentation,
Jean-Pierre Montanay. Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Monsieur Montanay, bonjour.
-Vous êtes le prolifique
auteur du "Chat",
un personnage de BD
qui vous rend célèbre en 1983.
Il fête donc ses 40 ans
cette année,
avec cet album.
Happy birthday, monsieur Geluck.
Il n'a pas pris une ride,
depuis sa naissance,
dans le journal francophone Le Soir,
où "Le chat"
est en noir et blanc.
Il passe à la couleur
dans la revue A suivre.
Ce que l'on sait moins,
c'est que vous l'avez créé
en 1980,
pour votre faire-part de mariage,
où il pose avec la femme du chat.
Cela a donné
de nombreuses bandes dessinées,
"Chacun son chat",
"L'avenir du chat",
"Chat alors"...
Non, ça, c'est pas vrai.
"Le chat" s'expose,
aussi, en 2003,
aux Beaux-Arts de Paris,
où le chat déambule,
comme en 2021,
sur les Champs-Elysées,
avec des statues monumentales
du félin.
Outre ce don pour le dessin,
vous êtes un artiste complet :
acteur, peintre, sculpteur,
chroniqueur,
présentateur d'émissions
de télévision,
en Belgique et en France.
On vous voit avec Michel Drucker.
La France, que vous avez choisi
pour le menu du jour, Jean-Pierre.
-Oui, exactement,
avec une blanquette de veau.
En dessert : un classique
de la pâtisserie française :
un Paris-Brest.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
rendez-vous pour les championnats
du monde de la frite.
On vous dévoilera le gagnant.
-Les pieds dans le plat :
L'Italie plébiscitée
pour sa cuisine.
Reportage dans un temple
dédié aux produits de la botte.
-On passe à table.
Tout de suite :
Cuisine et confidences.
Jingle
-Philippe Geluck,
que dit de vous
cette blanquette de veau ?
Pas facile à éclaircir.
La facilité aurait été
de donner ma langue au chat.
Je sais, c'est facile.
Non, j'ai cherché !
J'ai le début d'une hypothèse.
Pauvre Philippe Geluck,
vous êtes écartelé entre deux pays,
à cheval sur deux cultures,
donc sur deux cuisines.
Votre estomac penche
pour le waterzooï
et la mitraillette,
un totem de la malbouffe belge,
ce sandwich à la viande
et aux frites,
mais votre palais vote plutôt
pour le bon goût
de la France,
terre de gastronomie,
berceau de cette cuisine bourgeoise,
incarnée par cette blanquette
de veau,
qui mijote,
tandis qu'au coin du feu,
on caresse le chat qui ronronne.
Encore facile.
Image de cette recette
que vous nous imposez à nous,
Français,
au lieu de nous surprendre
avec des crevettes grises.
En filigrane,
il y a un message clair :
vous tenez à défendre une réputation
qui vous colle à la peau depuis
que vous êtes un visage familier
de notre télé,
celle du plus Français des Belges,
au prix de vexer Bruxelles.
Est-ce que je me trompe,
Philippe Geluck ?
-Complètement.
Vous êtes dans l'erreur.
Non, vous savez, à Bruxelles,
on est tellement habitués à tout ça.
Donc, pourquoi j'ai choisi
la blanquette de veau ?
Parce que ma grand-mère
la préparait comme personne.
-Divinement.
-En Belgique,
j'aurais pu vous demander
de faire des croquettes
aux crevettes,
mais vous savez pas les faire, ici,
ou des maatjes,
mais c'est pas la saison.
-On sait pas les faire
mais votre grand-mère belge
fait des blanquettes ?
-Oui.
-On en mange, en Belgique ?
-Bien sûr !
J'adore la cuisine française.
Sachez aussi une chose :
dans la partie sud du pays
où l'on parle français,
la France est notre deuxième pays,
c'est notre culture,
on lit la littérature française,
parce qu'on ne lit pas que
des auteurs belges, chez nous.
On lit des journaux français,
on regarde
la télé française.
Même si ce qui se fait en Belgique
est formidable et s'exporte
depuis quelques années
merveilleusement.
On a aussi une grande communauté
italienne, en Belgique.
On adore la cuisine italienne.
-On va en parler après.
Finalement,
vous êtes un peu écartelé
entre ces deux cultures.
-Non,
je m'enrichis d'accumuler
les cultures,
plutôt que de les diviser.
"Ecartelé", ça veut dire
qu'on est coupé en deux.
Au contraire,
j'ai des couches supplémentaires
car je me passionne
pour la culture des autres,
et que j'aime découvrir des saveurs.
Alors, là,
je suis très impatient.
-On va la goûter.
-Je peux y aller ?
-OUI.
-Je peux pas savoir
si elle est aussi bonne
que celle de votre grand-mère.
-C'est une recette
faite par Chez Françoise,
le restaurant à côté
de l'Assemblé nationale,
aux Invalides.
On espère qu'elle va ressembler
ou approcher
celle de votre grand-mère,
sans l'égaler, j'imagine.
-Hm ! En plus, ma grand-mère
s'appelait Françoise.
-Ah bah alors vous voyez,
ça tombe bien !
-Non, c'est pas vrai.
-Qu'est-ce qui faisait le secret
de cette blanquette de veau
de grand-mère ?
Est-ce que vous la fantasmiez
ou elle était très bonne ?
-Elle était très bonne.
Elle y mettait aussi...
Non, très bonne.
Bravo, Françoise.
-Bravo, Françoise.
-Elle y mettait
aussi des petites boulettes,
- des polpettes,
comme font les Italiens -
mais de viande de veau.
-C'est une blanquette revisitée,
un petit peu.
-Pas revisitée,
c'était une question de moyens.
Le veau coûtait plus cher.
La viande hachée
était meilleur marché.
Il y avait ce côté agréable.
-J'aime bien !
-Cela dit,
elle est délicieuse, j'adore.
Si vous aimez ça,
allez un jour
au bistrot d'Henri, rue Princesse,
dans le 6e.
Alors lui, il surpasse tout.
-La meilleure
de Paris, pour vous ?
-Oui, du monde,
de ma grand-mère, partout.
-J'allais vous demander une adresse.
-Rue Princesse, le bistrot d'Henri.
J'ai connu le papa.
Le fils a continué.
-Qu'est-ce qui fait une différence ?
C'est du veau, de la crème,
un oeuf, des champignons...
-Des carottes.
-Qu'est-ce qui fait
que rue Princesse,
c'est la princesse des blanquettes ?
-Qu'est-ce qui fait
que "Le chat" est "Le chat" ?
C'est un chat qui dit des conneries,
et pourtant, ça fait rire.
C'est la touche
du cuisinier.
-L'auteur fait le charme.
Jean-Pierre, trois astuces
pour revisiter la blanquette.
-Je rebondis
sur la grand-mère de Philippe.
-N'insultez pas ma famille !
-Elle l'a revisitée,
c'est une bonne idée,
avec des polpettes.
J'aurais pu le mettre
dans ce que je vais raconter.
Le veau est la viande-reine
de la blanquette,
mais toutes les viandes blanches
font l'affaire.
On peut mettre du poulet,
de la dinde, du lapin.
Osez les épices
pour réveiller la blanquette,
que certains trouvent pépère,
en mode asiatique : du gingembre
et de la citronnelle dans la crème,
pourquoi pas un peu de lait de coco,
en version des îles.
C'est bon avec un peu de vanille.
Vous grattez au dernier moment
une petite gousse de vanille
dans la crème.
Et en version corsée,
avec au dernier moment
un tour de moulin.
Vous mettez pas du poivre
mais du café.
Ca vous réveille.
-Si vous mettez de la vanille
dans la blanquette,
je vous mets un bouillon cube
dans la crème brûlée du dessert.
-Vous pouvez opter...
-Ca plaît pas beaucoup
à Philippe Geluck.
-J'ai vu.
On peut opter aussi
pour la blanquette au poisson :
le saumon, la lotte, la sole,
même des crevettes sont impec,
pour une blanquette un peu iodée.
-Savez-vous attendrir
la viande de veau,
qui doit être grasse et tendre ?
-Il faut taper dessus, comme Maïté.
-Ah non, c'est en douceur.
Vous la mettez dans un plat
avec de l'eau gazeuse,
pendant deux-trois heures.
-Ah bon ?
-Je ne sais pas par quel processus
de chimie, elle va s'attendrir.
-Il faut la laisser longtemps ?
-Ah oui ?
-Deux-trois heures.
-Est-ce que vous aimez cuisiner ?
Savez-vous faire
une blanquette de veau ?
-J'adore cuisiner.
Je vous préparerai
mes coquilles Saint-Jacques.
-Les recettes
de votre grand-mère ?
-Pas que.
Ca, elle l'a jamais fait.
C'est des coquilles Saint-Jacques
snackées
que je mets sur un lit
d'endives caramélisées.
-C'est le Nord, les endives.
-Les chicons.
-Oui, et je nappe
avec un beurre blanc.
-Un peu d'amertume.
-Plutôt des produits
de la mer ?
-Tout.
-Quel est votre plat signature,
outre ces coquilles Saint-Jacques ?
-J'aime beaucoup
la cuisine italienne,
l'osso buco de veau,
- décidément, encore du veau -
ou alors toutes sortes de pâtes,
je fais les lasagnes parfaites,
avec des lasagnes fraîches,
et j'ai découvert récemment
le cacio e pepe.
-On parlera tout à l'heure
de la cuisine italienne.
-Si vous voulez. Je les fais,
on est faits l'un pour l'autre.
-La cuisine française,
est-ce que vous aimez
les classiques ?
Là, c'est la blanquette de veau,
le boeuf bourguignon...
-Non.
-Pas du tout ?
Pour quelle raison ? C'est le vin ?
-Je préfère boire
le vin au verre
que dans l'assiette.
-Vous aimez faire le marché ?
Vous choisissez vos produits
en fonction de quoi ?
De la provenance ? De la localité ?
-De la saison,
de la provenance tant que je peux,
de la sympathie, aussi,
que j'ai pour les marchands.
-C'est vrai, ça joue.
S'il vend bien ses artichauts...
-Une fromagère qui me vendrait
un fromage exquis
en faisant la gueule, je préfère
manger un fromage moins bon
chez une fromagère sympa.
-Des fruits et des légumes
de saison, toujours ?
Vous faites attention ?
-Bien sûr.
-Vous faites attention
au bilan carbone ?
-Je suis très préoccupé par ça
depuis des années et des années.
J'ai découvert l'écologie
à travers René Dumont,
et ses écrits formidables
dans les années 70.
Ca ne m'a jamais quitté.
Quand je vois que c'est des haricots
du Kenya, j'évite.
-On fait vivre les cultivateurs
du Kenya, aussi.
-Mais c'est pas bon pour la planète.
Il faut choisir son combat.
-Sans les haricots,
ils peuvent crever de faim.
-Encourageons les Kényans
à manger des haricots locaux.
-Au marché, vous avez une idée
de votre cuisine
ou vous vous laissez guider
par les produits
pour faire une recette ?
-C'est plutôt ça.
Je me dis : "Tiens,
l'oeil de ce poisson a l'air vif,
"donc nous allons le ramener
à la maison."
Et puis, j'ai fait mienne
une des recommandations
de Bocuse,
dans sa "Cuisine du marché".
-Paul Bocuse,
le pape de la cuisine française.
-Il m'a ouvert les yeux
sur les merveilles de la gastronomie
et la façon de la réaliser.
Il conseillait de faire ses courses
après avoir mangé,
parce que si on y va en ayant faim
soi-même, on achète 10 fois trop.
-Ca, c'est sûr.
-C'est mal.
-Alors, "Le chat",
on le connaît bien,
puisque ça fait 40 ans, aujourd'hui,
qu'il accompagne nos vies.
Il fête ses bougies.
Le chat est un peu empâté,
quand même.
-Oui.
-Il faut le dire.
-Pourquoi l'avoir dessiné comme ça ?
-On a l'impression qu'il a mangé
l'intérieur du gâteau.
C'est un gourmand
mais c'est un gourmet,
qui préfère plutôt
les plats que j'affectionne
plutôt que de manger bêtement
des souris et des oiseaux,
comme font ses confrères
et consoeurs.
Il s'est arrondi avec les années.
Quand il est né, il était mince.
-Et fit, mince.
-Même les humains,
avec l'âge.
-J'ai pas pris un kilo.
-Sauf vous.
-Non, mais vous...
Vous êtes parfaits.
C'est le risque, évidemment,
avec l'âge.
-Pourquoi le chat a grossi ?
-Il a grossi
parce qu'il me faisait
davantage rire
un peu plus rond que mince.
-Comme un gros matou.
-Oui.
Pardon aux personnes en surpoids
qui nous regardent,
mais c'est vrai qu'une blague
racontée par un gros
ou racontée par un anorexique,
n'a pas le même effet.
-Surtout quand c'est une blague
autour de l'alimentation.
-Surtout que le personnage
n'existe pas vraiment.
Je ne me moque de personne,
il est simplement lui-même.
On me demandait aussi
pourquoi il avait un si gros nez.
Je dis :
"Imaginez-le avec un petit nez,
"il serait pas lui-même."
C'est un peu le Cyrano de Bergerac
des animaux.
-Vous êtes caricaturiste, aussi.
C'est un peu ça, votre trait.
-Notre métier consiste aussi
à exagérer, de temps en temps,
le trait.
-On va voir le chat,
parce qu'il parle beaucoup
d'alimentation.
On a ressorti quelques planches
qu'on va regarder ensemble.
"Cinq fruits ou légumes par jour,
"si on compte les fruits de mer,
c'est supportable."
C'est les coquilles Saint-Jacques !
-Oui, voilà !
-Il est plutôt plats en sauce
que fruits et légumes, le chat.
-Il avait fait un autre dessin...
J'avais fait un autre dessin.
Tu vois comme je suis...
-C'est politiquement incorrect.
Vous avez dû vous mettre
les diététiciens à dos.
-"On dit que l'appétit
vient en mangeant,
"force est de constater
"que l'appétit
part aussi en mangeant."
-Mais oui !
On n'a jamais dit ça !
-A la fin d'un repas,
on a moins d'appétit qu'au début.
-Quand vous avez dit
que les diététiciens
auraient pu me reprocher ce dessin,
j'ai fait un dessin sur eux :
"Un bon diététicien doit recevoir
cinq patients par jour,
"un avocat, un cornichon..."
Je sais plus
ce que j'avais encore inventé.
Alors, ça, c'est encore un dessin.
-"Soit j'ai encore pris un kilo,
"soit ma balance est passée
à l'heure d'été."
-Il sait qu'il est gros.
-Il vit bien avec.
-Oui.
-Vous avez aussi des engagements,
comme sur le bien-être animal.
Il peut en parler, le chat.
Il y a aussi une planche
où il est végétarien.
-Oui.
-C'est des messages
que vous voulez faire passer ?
-C'est selon.
Le lecteur fait comme il veut.
Je propose,
il analyse et il dispose.
Je me sers évidemment
des grands thèmes d'actualité
et non pas de l'actualité
au jour le jour.
Je ne vais pas
faire un commentaire
sur la déclaration
du député Machin-Chouette
à propos de la grève des trucs,
machin...
Non, parce que dans six mois,
et même dans deux semaines,
on passera à autre chose,
mes dessins n'auraient plus
de sens.
Si vous lisez...
Je vois qu'il y a l'album, ici...
-C'est un album historique.
-C'est le premier, paru en 86.
Si on lit des extraits
de cet album-là,
on rit encore.
C'est ce que disent
des enfants
de 10-12 ans,
qui découvrent
les anciens albums :
"Ca nous fait marrer,
c'est formidable."
Ca n'aurait pas été le cas
si c'était du dessin
sur l'actualité
politique du jour.
-On dit
qu'en vieillissant,
on prend du poids
et qu'on devient réac.
Est-ce que "Le chat",
idéologiquement,
il a changé
par rapport
à quand il était
beaucoup plus jeune ?
A 40 ans,
il est plus à droite ?
Ou est-ce qu'il a jamais été
à gauche ?
-Les strips,
c'est ces bandes en 3 cases.
Il a un jour fait
la comparaison.
Il a dit qu'en politique,
les gens commencent
à gauche,
passent au centre,
et terminent à droite.
"Comme moi,
dans ce strip."
Aucune allusion politique.
C'est un humaniste,
je pense que j'essaye
de l'être, moi aussi.
-Un républicain.
-Oui, plutôt
républicain
même si c'est le roi du gag.
Il prend toujours la défense
des plus faibles.
Et c'est son honneur.
J'ai fait des dessins
dans cet album
sur l'imposition du port
de la burqa.
-On a ressorti
ces quelques dessins.
On va les regarder
ensemble.
Avec une burqa,
justement...
On peut rire de tout.
-Ca vous fait rire.
Ca me fait plaisir de voir
votre grand sourire
en lisant ce dessin
car j'aborde un sujet
grave, tragique,
et j'arrive à en faire rire.
-Le chat est laïque ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Bien sûr...
Alors...
Personne n'a encore eu
la véritable preuve
de l'existence de Dieu.
On attend toujours.
Le chat a dit :
"S'il est si balèze,
"qu'il se fasse inviter
un jour au 20h."
Mais euh...
Moi, j'ai créé le chat.
Qu'un être croie
en son créateur,
c'est possible,
puisque j'existe.
Il croit en moi.
-C'est une forme de croyance.
Le chat est engagé
aussi pour des causes
qui sont aussi plus sensibles.
On regarde ensemble.
Rires
-Voilà.
C'est le dessin que j'ai oublié
de mettre dans l'album.
J'en ai un peu parlé
en présentant ce 24e "Chat".
Ce dessin-là,
il est pas stigmatisant.
Qui est-ce qui
est le plus fort ?
C'est le gamin.
Il a cette réplique.
"Je veux faire
du stand-up !"
Beaucoup de personnes
en situation de handicap,
des gens
en fauteuil roulant,
viennent
aux séances de dédicaces
et me disent :
"Merci
"de nous inclure
dans vos gags,
"ça nous fait exister
normalement."
-Est-ce que le chat peut
rire de tout ?
-Oui.
-Jamais vous ne vous êtes
interdit
un domaine,
une blague,
à cause de...
-"C'est trop méchant,
je le fais pas" ?
-Non.
Non, non.
Comme tout le monde,
j'ai des dessins
où je me dis
que c'est gratuit, pas bien.
Non, il a même réussi à dire
que si le prophète avait eu
un frère jumeau,
lui, le frère,
on aurait pu le représenter
sans aucun problème.
C'est une manière d'aborder ça.
-Le débat des caricatures
de Charlie.
-Voilà.
D'une façon détournée.
C'est aussi ça, la force
de l'humour, de la réflexion,
c'est de ne pas forcément
prendre la question frontalement,
puisqu'on sait qu'elle peut
générer de la tragédie,
mais de la prendre
par la bande.
Ca permet de parler
du sujet.
Ca permet de débattre.
Ca permet de faire
rire et réfléchir.
-Il a le sens
de l'esquive,
le chat.
Il sait contourner
un obstacle d'un coup.
-Malgré son embonpoint.
Rires
Il est parfois
très fin.
Petit jeu de mots.
-On va voir
si vous êtes vraiment incollable,
c'est le quiz.
-On a fait une exception pour vous.
Il porte d'habitude
sur la nourriture
des humains,
ce quiz,
mais pour vous,
ce sera sur la nourriture
des chiens et chats.
Dites-nous
si ces affirmations
qui vont venir
sont vraies.
Il lit la première affirmation.
-Vrai !
-Oui, c'est vrai.
-Bravo !
Il lit la deuxième affirmation.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Alors, je dirais vrai.
-C'était des viandes pas nobles,
pas chères,
donc on les réservait
aux conserves
de chats et chiens.
Plutôt une bonne idée.
Ensuite,
des tripes sont arrivées
et ont été mises en conserve.
Il lit la troisième affirmation.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Faux.
Je pense qu'il doit
y en avoir moins.
Mais comme souvent.
-4 % !
Selon la loi européenne.
4 % de poulet.
-Vous êtes incollable
sur la nourriture pour chats.
-D'où le slogan
"Ma boîte, c'est du poulet ?"
Il lit la quatrième information.
...
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je dirais vrai.
-Vrai pour le chocolat.
Vrai pour le blanc d'oeuf.
Faux pour les lentilles.
-Compliqué !
-Autrement,
il aurait eu tout juste.
Le piège, c'était les lentilles.
C'est très bon pour les chats.
-Très bien.
-Vous saurez pour l'avenir.
-Le chat,
dont nous parlons,
a un jour dit :
"Si les lentilles vont font péter,
portez
"des lunettes."
-Il peut le dire.
Rires
-Un deuxième quiz.
Vous avez prévu vos premiers dessins
dans L'oeuf.
Est-ce que ces affirmations
sur l'oeuf en cuisine
sont exactes ?
-Je croyais à une comparaison
avec ma coiffure.
-Je me serais pas permise.
-Je reconnais votre délicatesse.
Elle lit la première affirmation.
...
-Il est passé de date.
Une poche d'air s'est
agrandie dans la coquille.
-Effectivement,
il est périmé !
Elle lit la deuxième affirmation.
...
-Mollet ?
Non, il va être dur
à 8 minutes.
-6 minutes !
-Voilà !
C'est 3 minutes
pour le...
-Il est très fort.
-...l'oeuf à la coque
et 5 pour le mollet.
Elle lit la 3e affirmation.
...
-Vrai.
-C'est exact.
-C'est la cuisine
à basse température.
-Effectivement.
Elle lit la quatrième affirmation.
...
-J'ai eu des poules.
Je parle de l'animal, hein.
Rires
J'ai mangé
des oeufs frais
du jour,
on dit
que c'est pas
recommandé.
Mais c'est si bon.
Je dirais, l'oeuf,
dès qu'il est pondu,
je peux le manger.
-Mais quel est l'espace de temps
où il est toujours extra-frais ?
-Après 4 jours,
on peut encore
le manger à la coque ?
-A mon avis,
c'est un peu plus long.
-9 jours.
-Voilà.
-Alors, là,
félicitations.
C'est rare.
-Merci.
-Même avec des chefs,
c'est rare qu'on ait
une totale réussite.
-A part ce piège ignoble
qu'il m'a tendu
sur les lentilles.
-Pas fairplay.
-Si on travaille en proportion,
j'ai répondu bon à deux tiers
de la question.
-En fournissant même
les réponses, parfois.
Au degré près.
-Etes-vous aussi fort
sur le vin ?
Vous nous avez demandé
ce Morgon.
On est sur la région
du Beaujolais.
Domaine Lapierre,
il est bien connu là-bas.
C'est un vin rouge
de millésime 2022.
Le cépage,
c'est un Gamay.
Sa particularité,
en général, hein,
pour le Morgon,
il y a 4 arômes dominants,
cerise, violette,
framboise et réglisse.
C'est ça qui vous plaît ?
-Vous me l'apprenez.
Moi, je l'aime...
-Vous l'aimez
à déguster.
-Je l'aime
pour ce qu'il est.
Je le trouve
juste parfait.
C'est mon ami Siné,
le dessinateur
qui a fait les célèbres "Chats",
"Chat plin", etc...
Il m'a fait connaître
le Morgon Lapierre,
c'était un ami à lui.
Et c'est un...
C'est une famille
de viticulteurs
qui a toujours privilégié
la biodynamie bien avant
qu'on parle du vin bio
donc je le trouve parfait.
J'en consomme
avec modération.
-Evidemment.
Avec modération.
C'est souvent
autour de la table
que se nouent
les meilleures histoires,
que se fait parfois
le deal en politique.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
On vous a demandé
de réfléchir
à une anecdote,
pourquoi pas en politique,
autour d'un repas.
Est-ce que vous avez
un souvenir
particulièrement marquant
à nous raconter ?
-Alors, marquant
et très personnel.
Je demande pardon à l'avance
à la personne si elle souhaite
que je ne révèle pas cela.
J'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
plusieurs fois François Hollande,
chez des amis.
Des amis communs
qui le connaissaient bien.
Même chez un couple de journalistes,
lorsqu'il était président.
Nous avons dîné chez eux.
Avec lui.
Et c'est quelqu'un
de très sympathique.
-Très drôle.
Lors de l'une de ses visites
à Bruxelles,
nous avons eu la chance
qu'il accepte une invitation
à dîner à la maison,
avec un grand médecin
qui est le bras droit
du docteur Mukwege,
"l'homme qui répare les femmes".
Très belle cause.
-Prix Nobel.
-Voilà.
Et ce soir-là,
j'avais préparé,
je pense, mes petites coquilles
Saint-Jacques
dont je vous avais parlé,
il s'était régalé.
Julie Gayet était là.
Et au moment des fromages,
je lui ai apporté
une planche
sur laquelle j'avais mis
un camembert Président
et un morceau de Hollande
de demi vieux.
-Ca lui a plu,
l'attention particulière ?
-Ca l'a fait rire :
"Pourquoi du demi vieux ?"
J'ai dit : "Je ne vais pas
vous servir du Hollande jeune."
-On va continuer.
Vous nous avez demandé
une blanquette,
mais ni frites,
ni bière, ni chocolat,
qui sont des spécialités belges.
On a décidé de faire plaisir
à nos téléspectateurs
et de parler de la frite
et de ses secrets
de fabrication.
C'est le dessous des plats.
Dans le nord, on ne plaisante pas
avec la frite.
Est-ce là-bas qu'elles sont
les meilleurs ?
La ville d'Arras a décidé
d'organiser le premier championnat
du monde du genre.
Maïté Frémont et nos confrères
de Frances Télévisions
ont joué les juges.
-Plus qu'une spécialité
culinaire, presque
un objet de culte...
-La frite, c'est la vie.
-...au pays
de la pomme de terre,
une bonne
frite fait tache d'huile
chez les amateurs
et chez les professionnels.
-La frite, c'est la convivialité,
la sympathie,
la fraîcheur, et la fête.
-C'est un produit régional
qui réchauffe le coeur
et les papilles.
-Dans le Nord, on ne blague pas
avec la frite.
-On a tout ?
-Oui.
J'ai même pas vérifié.
-Avant d'entrer en scène,
Thomas stresse.
-C'est une première.
Elle donne le temps et tout.
On est sous pression, là.
-Le concours est lancé, top chrono :
une heure pour éplucher,
tailler et frire
les pommes de terre.
L'objectif est clair :
casser la baraque en faisant
la meilleure frite du monde.
Thomas mise tout
sur un ingrédient secret.
-On essaie
de faire la diff' avec le sel
à l'ail noir. On verra.
-Mais pour ce tout premier
championnat du monde
de la frite,
la concurrence est rude.
32 candidats s'affrontent :
chacun choisit sa variété
de pomme de terre et son huile.
Dans la catégorie
frite familiale, les frères Benjamin
et Yohan veulent se démarquer.
-On part sur une variété
qui n'est pas destinée à la frite,
on part sur une grande charlotte,
et on la fait en trois cuissons,
donc à 130-140,
170-180 et un dernier bain à 190.
-Des candidats français, belges,
mais aussi
canadiens ou japonais, avec
cette recette de frite soufflée.
L'art de la frite, une maîtrise
loin d'être facile.
Qu'en disent les membres du jury ?
-Elles sont appétissantes,
bien dorées.
Elles sont bien assaisonnées.
-Le croustillant à l'extérieur
et la texture
à l'intérieur.
On a des candidats
de haute qualité.
-Dans une ambiance populaire,
le public aussi s'en régale.
-Très bonnes,
croustillantes,
bons bouts de pommes de terre.
Comme on les aime, génial.
Musique légère
-Et le premier champion du monde
de la frite est français.
-Une belle conclusion
pour une journée fatigante
et quelques semaines
de préparation.
Et surtout, ça récompense le travail
que je fais tous les jours.
-Un Lillois l'emporte
avec une recette
de tubercules cuites
à l'huile puis au gras
de boeuf,
quoi de plus naturel,
dans cette région qui garde
la patate depuis des siècles ?
-C'est un Français
qui est champion du monde
de la frite, c'est un affront ?
-Non, il a certainement
fait un stage chez nous.
J'ai observé trois choses
qui me plaisent.
On a parlé d'huile
et de blanc de boeuf...
-Gras de boeuf.
-On appelle ça blanc de boeuf.
Un peu de deux.
On a parlé de plusieurs bains.
L'erreur, c'est de cuire
les frites une fois.
Alors deux ou trois,
mais le dernier,
un peu plus chaud,
c'est important.
Et j'ai vu que des personnes
dégustaient une barquette
avec de la mayonnaise.
En Belgique, on mange des frites
-Toujours ?
-Sinon,
c'est péché !
-C'est péché ?
-A Paris, on n'arrive pas
à convaincre nos amis
qu'il faut essayer.
-C'est de la mayonnaise
ou une sauce ? J'ai entendu dire
que c'était une sauce.
-Vous avez la tartare,
la mayonnaise,
la sauce andalouse...
Mais avec la mayonnaise...
Je vous recommande
de venir au mois de novembre,
s'il fait froid
et qu'il pleuvine,
à Bruxelles, vous prenez
un cornet de frites,
vous vous mettez sous un abri
de bus et vous dégustez
un paquet de frites brûlantes...
-Vous allez les achetez
forcément à la friterie
ou vous en faites ?
-Non, à la friterie
ou au restaurant.
-Vous n'en faites pas ?
Trop galère ? Ca sent mauvais ?
-Ca sent la frite.
-Ca représente quoi,
la frite,
pour vous ?
On entendait : "C'est la vie."
-C'est magnifique.
Régulièrement, avec des copains,
on va se faire un cinéma
en fin d'après-midi
et on termine
à la friterie.
-Debout, avec votre cornet
de frites ?
-Oui, bien sûr, et on va se boire
une bière belge
avec un cornet de frites...
-C'est un repas complet,
pour vous ?
-Oui !
On va pas dîner après.
-Les cardiologues disent
plutôt : "La frite, c'est le gras."
-Bien sûr !
Avec modération.
Quand on boit un coup,
il faut le dire,
avec une frite, c'est pareil.
-Vous en mangez régulièrement ?
-Non.
J'en mange une fois par 10 jours.
-Par 10 jours ?
-Bien sûr.
-Nous,
c'est tous les 6 mois.
-On peut mettre n'importe
quelle variété ?
Certains ont tenté des choses
avec des pommes de terre
qui ne sont pas utilisées
pour la frite.
-En principe, c'est la bintje.
-Pour vous,
c'est seulement la bintje ?
-J'ai pas poussé
les analyses plus avant.
-Il y a un débat
sur les chairs fermes
et un peu moins fermes.
-C'est plutôt farineuse.
Oui, parce que la chair ferme,
ça peut...
Il mâche.
-Elle peut être longue à cuire,
la chair ferme.
-Elle ressemble
à quoi, une bonne frite ?
Large, plutôt allumette ?
Comment elle doit être ?
-C'est cette taille-là.
-Taille du doigt ?
-Les pommes allumettes,
c'est mignon,
mais autant manger
des chips.
Les frites trop grosses,
c'est épouvantable.
Autant faire des croquettes
dans la chapelure...
-On a l'impression
de manger de la purée.
-J'ai pas mesuré avant de venir,
mais je vous garantis
que vous venez à la...
Chez nous, on dit "à la friture",
pas "à la friterie".
-Ah oui ?
-Oui.
-Venez à la friture Antoine
place Jourdan à Bruxelles,
le quartier de mon enfance,
où j'y vois
les arrière-petits-enfants
du créateur.
C'est une tradition.
-C'est culturel, en fait ?
-Oui, et puis c'est bon,
tout simplement.
-Elle croustille
à l'extérieur
et fondante à l'intérieur ?
-Oui, voilà.
Oui, elle doit être vraiment dorée.
Vous pouvez demander bien cuite.
Il y a rien de pire
qu'une frite molle.
-Oui...
Vous disiez que la meilleure
blanquette était à Paris,
mais c'est pas à Paris
qu'on trouve la meilleure frite ?
-On est champions !
-Mais il est de Lille.
-Il est de Lille.
-Dès qu'on s'éloigne du Nord,
on arrive à manger
des bonnes frites ?
-Bien sûr.
-Est-ce que la frite
a conquis toute la France ?
-On mange plus de frites
en France
qu'en Belgique.
C'est des chiffres qui m'ont amusé.
Mais je trouve qu'il y a
des nourritures, des boissons,
qui sont liées à un pays
ou à une région.
Buvez un pastis
sur le port de Marseille,
parfait.
Vous buvez le même pastis
devant la gare de Dusseldorf,
il n'aura pas la même saveur.
-Il aura pas
le même goût !
Est-ce qu'à l'aveugle,
vous sauriez reconnaître
une frite maison
d'une frite surgelée ?
-Bien sûr.
-C'est vrai ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Ca me fait rebondir,
mais j'aime bien
citer le chat, parce qu'il dit :
"Dégustation à l'aveugle,
"le plus dur est de trouver
le tire-bouchon."
Donc des frites à l'aveugle,
ça peut être compliqué.
Mais si on m'aide à les manger, oui.
Jamais de frites surgelées !
C'est une hérésie.
-Une bonne
frite surgelée peut être meilleure
qu'une mauvaise
frite pas surgelée.
-Si on va par-là,
bien sûr,
un excellent verre d'eau
peut être meilleur
qu'un vin de merde.
Je montre pas celui-là,
évidemment.
-On voit apparaître
des frites de patate douce,
des frites de taro.
Vous admettez cette concurrence
ou vous trouvez que sur la frite,
c'est la patate ?
-Ah non,
frire est le propre de l'homme.
Donc faisons frire
tout ce qu'on peut faire frire.
Plus on frit et plus...
-On peut l'appeler frite ?
-Plus on est de fous,
plus on frit.
-On peut quand même
l'appeler frite ?
-Non, on appelle ça
patate douce frite ou...
beignet de carotte
ou de machin frit.
-Il faudrait
une AOC frite pour vous.
-Madame,
la frite, c'est la pomme de terre.
-On trouve aussi
beaucoup de frites à cuir au four.
Vous trouvez que c'est
une anomalie ?
-Non, je l'ai tenté,
mais j'en suis revenu.
C'est pas terrible.
D'abord, il y a
une dépense d'énergie
considérable pour faire
chauffer un four à 200 degrés
pour cuire
une assiette de frites,
c'est un peu aberrant.
-C'est moins bon ?
-Oui, restons au...
Il y a des trucs...
-Vous aimez
les traditions, vous.
-J'aime
revisiter les choses, mais si
la visite n'est pas concluante,
je reviens à la tradition.
Faire bien,
effectuer bien
un plat traditionnel
ou préparer admirablement
un mets...
Un oeuf au plat, ça peut être raté,
ça peut être réussi.
Si le jaune devient un peu dur
à la fin, c'est pas bien.
Donc ça doit être parfait.
L'oeuf au plat, oui,
on le prépare
depuis des siècles
sans doute,
mais je tire mon chapeau toujours
à la personne
qui me fait
un très bel oeuf au plat.
-Est-ce que le chat va à la friture
de temps en temps ?
Je n'ai pas trouvé de frites
avec le chat,
mais j'imagine...
-J'ai dû faire des dessins
sur Bruxelles,
mais vous savez, les...
J'ai fait un jour un dessin
où il est attablé
avec des frites
et une bière, et il dit :
"Tout le monde s'étonne de voir
un chat manger des frites
"et personne ne s'étonne qu'il soit
en train de boire une bière."
Mais c'est plutôt
anecdotique.
C'est pas le message que je veux
porter à travers la planète,
de dire : "Attention,
je suis originaire de là
"et je veux que ça se sache."
-On va parler
de la cuisine italienne.
C'est une de vos cuisines
préférées,
mais est-elle meilleure que
notre gastronomie française ?
On met les pieds dans le plat.
-Soyons chauvins :
la meilleure gastronomie
est sans doute la française.
Soyons honnêtes :
la cuisine plébiscitée
de Tokyo à San Francisco
en passant par chez nous
et la Belgique,
c'est l'italienne.
La preuve avec ce reportage
d'Hélène Bonduelle
et de Philippe Lecroc.
"Sarà Perché Ti Amo",
Ricchi e Poveri
...
-De la burrata avec
de la crème de pois chiche.
C'est super bon.
-C'est goûtu, joli, coloré
et on se régale.
-C'est la cuisine
la plus populaire au monde,
celle de la botte.
94 % des Français déclarent
que la cuisine italienne
est leur cuisine préférée.
Une passion de longue date
mais ravivée ces derniers temps
par l'ouverture de restaurants
ou de concept stores, comme ici,
en plein coeur de Paris :
2500 mètres carrés
entièrement dédiés à l'Italie.
-Tout vient d'Italie.
Toutes les régions
sont représentées.
Différents types de lait :
chèvre, vache, bufflonne.
En charcuterie,
vous avez les spécialités
iconiques, la mortadelle,
le jambon de Parme,
le San Daniele, et après,
des choses
un peu plus précises
comme la bresaola
de différents types.
-5000 références
de produits italiens,
5 restaurants
et la plus grande cave
de vins italiens aussi.
-Avec plus de 14 000 bouteilles,
1500 références.
On a des vins de toutes les régions,
du nord au sud de l'Italie,
des vins des îles,
de la Sicile.
-Mais alors, d'où vient
cette passion française
pour cette gastronomie ?
Sans surprise,
c'est une cliente italienne
qui nous en parle le mieux.
-Elle est joyeuse et variée.
Je pense que c'est ça.
Elle est très gourmande.
Elle est riche, en fait,
mais aussi simple.
Il n'y a pas besoin d'ingrédients
particulièrement riches
pour faire des recettes qui soient
bonnes et sympa à partager.
-En parlant de recettes,
Philippe Geluck,
nous avions une spécialité
à vous proposer.
-Je pense qu'il serait
intéressé par un guanciale
qu'il pourrait préparer
pour faire des pasta
alla carbonara,
une mezzo pacchero qui vient
bien absorber cette sauce
qui est faite à base d'oeufs,
avec le guanciale,
qui est un produit assez salé,
un peu croquant
parce qu'on le fait griller,
donc ça donne un plat
gourmand et généreux.
Je pense que ça lui plairait.
-Les pâtes, justement,
savez-vous que plus de 14 milliards
d'assiettes de pâtes
sont consommées chaque année
à travers le monde ?
-Quiz : j'ose même pas demander
ce que c'est que le guanciale.
-C'est de la joue
de sanglier.
-Ou de porc.
-Le vrai, c'est de sanglier.
"Carbonara", ça vient
des types qui faisaient
du charbon de bois
dans les montagnes.
-Ca pourrait vous plaire ?
-Oui, j'adore ça,
le guanciale.
-Mais vous faites
la vraie carbonara,
sans la crème,
juste avec l'oeuf ?
-Comme le cacio e pepe...
-C'est pecorino et poivre,
c'est ça ?
-Oui.
-Ca m'étonne
que vous ayez découvert
le cacio e pepe
il y a pas longtemps.
-Je le connaissais, mais
je me suis risqué à le faire.
-C'est compliqué.
-J'ai réussi du premier coup.
C'est facile.
Je passe toutes mes vacances
en Italie,
dans un coin perdu
de l'Ombrie,
et quand on dit qu'il faut regarder
la provenance des produits,
je vous jure que c'est vrai,
dans la grande surface
de la petite ville
à côté de chez nous,
je trouve
des tomates de Hollande,
en plein été...
-C'est débile.
-...vendues
au milieu de l'Italie.
Qui sont ces crétins
qui font rouler des camions
pour transporter des tomates
de Hollande alors qu'on est
dans le pays de la tomate
et d'emmener de l'eau gazeuse
dans le nord ?
Il y a une aberration,
et on devrait légiférer
à ce propos.
-Vous êtes plus pasta
ou pizza ?
-Ah, la pasta.
La pizza, je trouve que...
Je prépare,
selon la recette
d'une vieille cuisinière
du sud de l'Italie,
la pizza fritta.
-C'est quoi, ça ?
Avec des frites ?
-Non, tu fais
une pâte à pizza
et au lieu de la garnir
et de la cuire au four,
tu prépares la garniture,
une sauce tomate,
avec quelques feuilles
de basilic,
et tu mets
dans un tout petit peu d'huile
dans une poêle en fonte.
-Ah oui !
-Et tu fais frire la pâte...
-Ca doit être bon, ça.
-C'est sublime.
-C'est de quelle région ?
-Je sais pas.
-C'est une margherita
mais frite, non ?
-Non, et le dessus n'est pas fondu.
C'est très bon.
Donc plutôt pâtes que pizza,
bien sûr.
C'est infini, les recettes
de préparation sont infinies.
La plus simple
est la meilleure.
-Avec un peu d'huile d'olive
et de l'ail.
-Chaque Italien
rêve des pâtes de sa maman :
les pâtes sauce tomate.
-Vous êtes
très vigilant
sur la cuisson al dente ?
-Non, j'aime pas
quand c'est trop dur.
Mais il faut pas non plus
que ce soit tout à fait mou.
-Vous inventez des recettes
autour des pâtes ?
-Oui, mais je me souviens plus
de ce que j'ai inventé.
Oui, bien sûr,
je tente des choses.
-On peut mettre
beaucoup de choses
avec les pâtes.
-On fait une sauce
avec les restes du frigo.
-Il faut vérifier
ce qu'on a dans le frigo.
Un jour, un type
s'est laissé prendre.
Il avait des vieux médicaments
à conserver au frais,
et toute sa famille...
Rires
-Vous préparez régulièrement
des pâtes à la maison ?
-Oui. Le plus simple,
c'est le bolo,
le fameux bolo,
qu'eux appellent al ragù
parce que...
-Bolognaise, quoi.
-Oui, c'est de la viande hachée
frite avec des oignons
et des tomates.
-Si on veut la faire mieux,
il peut y avoir un peu de vin,
de céleri, de tomate,
de carotte, d'oignon,
si on veut faire le ragù.
-Eh bien non, monsieur.
-Ce n'est pas
la vraie recette.
-On ajoute un peu de lard
de Colonnata.
-Ah, peut-être.
C'est pas qu'on le fait mieux,
c'est qu'on le fait autrement.
Mais pour moi,
c'est le truc de base :
oignon, tomate, huile d'olive
et on fait la meilleure sauce tomate
du monde.
Pas besoin de rajouter forcément
de l'origan ou de l'ail
ou des trucs comme ça.
Après, on peut aussi.
Je ne déteste pas,
mais j'aime bien le basique.
-Pourquoi on est tous fous
de la cuisine italienne,
à votre avis ?
-Bonne question.
-Contrairement à l'idée reçue,
elle est très variée,
parce que leurs produits
sont excellents,
et parce que...
Et parce que c'est bon.
-Tout simplement.
Simple aussi.
-Et on parle de tout ça
devant un paris-brest
qui me fait les yeux doux.
-C'est la culture du produit
en Italie.
Vous allez dans la moindre
petite épicerie,
il y a du fromage à la découpe,
de la charcuterie à la découpe.
Il y a plein d'appellations,
de variétés, d'espèces
qu'on n'a pas en France,
où on est très vite sur des produits
déjà empaquetés.
-Et la moindre trattoria
est excellente.
-Exactement.
-Vous préférerez
aller dans une trattoria
que dans un étoilé.
-Ah oui. Mais sur la terrasse
de la trattoria,
s'il fait beau,
j'ai le ciel étoilé au-dessus de moi
donc j'ai les deux.
-Vous connaissez bien
les différentes pâtes ?
Il y a les spaghettis,
il y a les orecchiette,
les tortellinis...
-Les macaronis,
les penne, les mini penne,
les orecchiette...
Oui, je connais tout
par coeur.
-Et vous variez ?
-Bien sûr.
-Vous avez l'impression
que c'est pas le même plat,
quand on change de...
-Certaines pâtes,
comme le défendent
les spécialistes
de la cuisine italienne,
accrochent mieux
tel ou tel genre de sauce.
-La sauce
se niche mieux
dans les pâtes cylindriques.
-Il faut mélanger la sauce
dans la casserole
retirée du feu
plutôt que de servir
des assiettes
sur lesquelles
on met de la sauce.
-Vous remettez
les pâtes dans la sauce
avant de les servir ?
-Oui.
-Il est italien
ou belge ?
Vous connaissez
la cucina povera ?
-Si.
-Vous aimez ?
Les pâtes aux patates,
par exemple ?
-J'ai jamais...
-C'est léger !
-Non,
vous mangez deux fois moins de pâtes
et deux fois moins
de patates qu'un plat de pâtes
ou qu'un plat de patates.
Avec un peu de pancetta
et du romarin,
c'est extraordinaire.
-C'est juste
un peu calorique.
-Et les pâtes aux frites ?
-Non, aux pois chiches.
Cucina povera, encore.
-Ils ont aussi l'arte povera
en Italie,
mais quelle richesse.
-En France, on a
beaucoup de fromages.
Le général de Gaulle disait :
"Comment gouverner un pays
"aux 258 variétés de fromages ?"
En Italie,
il y a 54 appellations.
Est-ce que vous êtes fan aussi
de ces fromages italiens ?
On raffole
de la mozzarella
ou de la burrata,
en France.
-Mozzarella di bufala
seulement,
parce que la mozzarella de vache
m'intéresse pas.
Le pecorino, c'est magnifique.
On avait un voisin
qui en faisait lui-même.
Le parmesan, n'en parlons pas.
Toujours le Reggiano
parce que le Grana Padano.
-C'est pas du parmesan,
le Grana Padano.
-Il se fait passer pour.
-Vous l'avez débusqué ?
-Oui, oui.
Alors...
Mais tout.
C'est formidable.
Comment appelle le fromage
avec du vers ?
Qui est coulant...
-Le mascarpone ?
Le gorgonzola ?
-Gorgonzola !
-Des fromages italiens...
-Quand on fait
ses courses là-bas,
il faut être à côté d'une dame
qui fait ses courses,
une Italienne,
et prendre ce qu'elle a commandé.
J'ai découvert un saucisson,
un "salame toscano".
Elle dit :
"Due etti di salame toscano."
Alors, je dis : "La stessa cosa."
-Le Villani
est très bon,
avec peu de gras.
-Si vous êtes dans une ville
que vous ne connaissez pas
et que vous voulez découvrir
un bon petit restaurant,
vous vous mettez
à une terrasse de bistrot
à côté de trois vieux pépères
qui prennent l'apéro.
Quand ils se lèvent,
vous les suivez.
Eux connaissent
le bon petit resto.
-Vous allez chez l'habitant,
sinon.
-C'est ça.
-Vous préférez quels fromages ?
J'ai l'impression
que c'est l'Italie.
-Ah non.
Je suis très fromages français.
Aussi, bien sûr.
Je trouve que...
Nous sommes complémentaires.
Je vous parlerai
dans une autre émission
des fromages belges,
dont il y a
une infinité de variétés.
-Ah bon ?
Vous le saviez, ça ?
-On les connaît moins.
-Le roi Baudouin
a dit un jour :
"Régner sur un pays
aux 263 fromages, c'est compliqué."
-Mozza ou burrata ?
Il y a un débat,
il y a un duel entre les deux.
-Mozzarella ou burrata...
Non, je trouve la burrata trop...
Il y a pas de la burrata
de bufflonne.
-Non. Non.
-Non.
Donc, s'il y en avait,
peut-être que
ça pourrait m'intéresser.
Non, plutôt la mozzarella
de bufflonne.
Et alors, la tresse...
-La burrata,
en fait,
n'est pas tellement dégustée
en Italie.
-Elle est enrichie de crème.
-Nous, on en raffole,
mais eux pas tellement.
-Exact.
La mozzarella de bufflonne,
c'est un fromage qui est ancestral
et qui était considéré
comme un fromage prestigieux
au 16e siècle.
C'était côté à la Bourse.
Pour riposter à ce fromage,
d'un point de vue
marketing,
les Pouilles ont inventé
cette burrata,
mais effectivement,
elle plaît davantage
aux bobos parisiens
qu'aux Italiens.
C'est un fromage un peu marketé,
la burrata.
-Enrichi à la crème fraîche.
-C'est une enveloppe
de mozza
avec de la crème.
-C'est comme tous les produits
qu'on nous vend, genre chips,
il y a du gras,
du sucre et du sel,
et ça attire... Pardon.
-Est-ce que le chat voyage ?
Est-ce qu'il a déjà été
en Italie ?
-Il est traduit en italien.
-Il est traduit en italien ?
-Oui.
"Il gatto".
Ils rient.
-Lui-même...
-Non... Il voyage avec moi
quand je le dessine là-bas.
Sinon,
il n'a pas fait de...
Il n'a pas pris ses valises
pour aller en Italie.
-Je vois
que vous lorgnez
sur ce paris-brest.
On passe au dessert.
C'est votre Péché mignon.
-"Il gatto",
la transition
est toute faite
avec le paris-brest.
Ils rient.
C'est un must
de la pâtisserie française.
Vous savez
que ce fromage rappelle
la roue d'un cycliste.
-Je vous rappelle
que vous avez dit
"ce fromage".
Rires
-Ce dessert rappelle
la roue d'un vélo
parce qu'il avait été fait
par un pâtissier
de Maisons-Laffitte,
en hommage à cette course,
qui s'appelle Paris-Brest.
J'ai aussi découvert une course
qui s'appelait Paris-Bruxelles.
Est-ce qu'il y a un dessert
qui a été fait comme ça,
en hommage à Paris-Bruxelles ?
-Je l'ai appris
il y a pas très longtemps.
C'est un grand cuisinier bruxellois,
dont le nom m'échappe,
et je lui demande pardon,
mais je le cite toujours.
Vous voyez ce que c'est,
la gaufre de Bruxelles ?
C'est une grande gaufre
très légère,
saupoudrée de sucre glace.
Eh bien, il a coupé
cette gaufre en deux
dans le sens de la longueur
et il y a mis le praliné
qu'on met dans le paris-brest.
Il a appelé ça le "paris-bruxelles".
-Ah ben voilà.
-C'est trop joli.
-Vous en trouvez finalement...
-Non, il a fait ça
lors d'une soirée spéciale
de relations Paris-Bruxelles,
mais je voudrais
qu'il le commercialise.
-Officiellement.
C'est pas la même pâte.
Là, c'est une pâte à choux.
C'est assez différent
de la pâte de la gaufre.
-Il est très, très beau.
-Il est gourmand.
-Chez Françoise l'a cuisiné
pour nous aujourd'hui.
J'imagine que vous avez
vos adresses
à Paris
pour trouver des paris-brest.
-Non, alors...
En télé, c'est odieux
quand on voit...
Ils rient.
-Pas très facile.
-Il y a des paris-brest
carrés, maintenant.
Ca vous choque ?
C'est une hérésie ?
Ou peu importe ?
-Ou en forme d'éclair.
On trouve de tout, maintenant.
-Qu'on s'amuse,
avec la forme, c'est même pas...
Non, c'est... Oh !
Il est très, très bon.
Bravo, Françoise.
-Vous en trouvez aussi,
à Bruxelles ?
Le vrai
paris-brest
avec la pâte à chou ?
-Non, chez nous,
on mange des frites.
-Voilà. Et vous n'avez pas envie
de le manger là-bas ?
C'est comme le pastis...
-A Dusseldorf.
Un paris-brest à Hong-Kong,
ça n'a pas le même...
Et avec des baguettes,
c'est pas facile.
-Est-ce que vous avez d'autres
desserts que vous nous enviez,
depuis la Belgique ?
-Mmmmh...
On n'est pas mauvais
dans les desserts, on a...
Est-ce qu'il y a des choses...
Par exemple, chez nous,
l'éclair au chocolat,
il est fourré de crème pâtissière
et non pas
de crème brune au chocolat.
-Ah oui ?
-Donc c'est pas un éclair
au chocolat, en fait ?
-Si, parce qu'il y a un nappage,
un glaçage
de chocolat.
-D'accord.
-Eh, pouêt-pouêt !
-On est quand même
les champions
de la pâtisserie, non ?
-Mais vous êtes les meilleurs.
Attendez, on va conclure ce...
Vous êtes...
parfaits,
dans tous les domaines.
Vous avez éclairé le monde
de votre intelligence
et de votre savoir.
-A partir
du 18e siècle.
-A une époque.
Maintenant, 2-3 ampoules
sont grillées mais vous continuez.
Vous avez la meilleure
gastronomie
du monde.
Vous avez sans doute
les meilleurs pâtissiers,
vous avez
les meilleurs vins du monde.
Vous avez...
le personnel polit...
Non, je vais pas aller sur ce...
Ils rient.
-J'ai peur
de la chute !
-N'en jetez plus !
-Et vous avez les meilleurs lecteurs
du "Chat" du monde,
le chat est tellement heureux
d'être lu dans ce pays.
C'est un grand bonheur.
-Vous fréquentez
les bars aux chats ?
J'ai vu que ça existait.
-Les bars "à" chats ?
-Non.
-Ben alors ? Vous devriez y faire
des conférences !
-Vous croyez honnêtement
que j'ai que ça à foutre ?
-Merci d'avoir
été avec nous
pour partager ce repas.
-Merci à vous !
Merci à Chez Françoise
qui nous a fourni ces bons plats.
Merci, Jean-Pierre,
merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis.
A la semaine prochaine
pour "Politiques, à table !",
sur LCP.